the coalition for zero fatalities
telling us this year is on track to be
the deadliest year on nevada roadways in
10 years heading into the labor day
holiday weekend they're putting on a
push to stop traffic fatalities or
hector mejia live right now near sahara
and the strip with a little more
information what are they doing there
hector
yeah hey there good morning to you naval
we're told traffic fatalities here to
date are up 30 percent and the numbers
are tragic and that's why we're here
we're talking about preventing more
traffic fatalities joining us live this
morning we have andrew bennett with the
coalition zero fatalities to talk to us
about the big push this weekend good
morning to you good morning hector and
that's exactly right unfortunately way
too many lives have been lost on our
roadways so far this year and that's why
it's vital that again we're pushing for
that sober weekend making sure that we
have people you know enjoy our great
city enjoy our great state but make sure
that we have a sober designated driver
home on the way home this evening and on
top of impaired driving we're also
highlighting reckless driving too also a
problem here on our roadways yeah we've
unfortunately seen it already this week
you know we had a crash down in gene
that was due to extreme speed
but these also happen on our side
streets and our our neighborhood roads
and that's why it's important that we
always slow down
and you know avoid that street racing
and that mentality of you're the most
important person on behind the wheel and
on that note tell us about this location
what brought us to this live location we
had a fatality here not too long ago
unfortunately that's exactly right we
had a reckless motorcycle in the area
you know anytime that you have cars
turning in front of each other that's a
deadly combination especially with
vulnerable road users like a motorcycle
and so over the last five years we've
had five fatalities here and you can see
they're making improvements with the
construction and that's always a good
thing awesome and we also have a bit of
a help for those who want to go out this
weekend with free lift rides fifteen
thousand dollars in free lift credits i
had we have the code here but tell us
about that initiative so through the las
vegas coalition for zero fatalities we
have several partners including the
cosmopolitan las vegas pt's
entertainment uh and a variety of
different others to make sure that we're
able to offer that ten dollars off one
ride and you can find that code at zero
fatalities nv on twitter and on facebook
awesome so yeah that code
is valid starting at 6 pm tonight up
until monday morning so everyone out
there if you're heading out this weekend
if you're staying in town drive safely
stay safe and also you know drive sober
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys